buongiorno a tutti oggi essere qui con
voi ad avere un emozione essere qui poi
in questo ambiente fantastico
quando qualche settimana fa mi cui fui
chiamato mi fu proposto di partecipare
accettai con grandissimo piacere sia per
partecipare a the decs sia per
l'amicizia con gli organizzatori ma
appunto per l'emozione di essere un
ambiente come questo
ecco cosa rappresentano per voi le
dolomiti
me ne sono posto quando fui chiamato
ecco per me le dolomiti sono un po
l'allegoria il paradigma della vita cioè
la bellezza ma anche la sfida rispetto
agli obiettivi difficili che ci sono
davanti a noi e alla voglia di mettersi
in gioco per raggiungerli
vorrei iniziare ricordando liviero
bellinzani non ho avuto il piacere di
conoscerlo ma mi piace ricordarlo perché
è stata una persona che ha molto amato
questi monti oliviero nel 1977 ed un
incidente stradale persona gamba
nonostante questo continuo ad amare la
montagna continua ad amare le dolomiti e
continuò a scalare le montagne fino a
qualche giorno fa al 22 agosto quando
purtroppo ci lasciò per causa in un
incidente in montagna
ecco cosa diceva olivieri oliviero
sosteneva che se si vuole ottenere molto
bisogna essere disposti a pagare molto
soltanto così è possibile entrare dentro
le cose oltre l'apparenza sino a viverle
e sentirle come proprie ecco in questo
le dolomiti sono davvero la metafora di
ciò che abbiamo di fronte a noi nella
vita
oggi non vorrei condividere con voi le
mie esperienze di camminata in montagna
che sarebbero ben poca cosa rispetto a
molti di voi ma invece condividere il
percorso che ho fatto
in quest'ultimo anno come responsabile
dell'agenzia italiana per il turismo un
brevissimo accenno cos'è l'agenzia
italiana per il turismo diciamo che
l'italia come qualsiasi altra nazione al
mondo credo a un'agenzia che la promuove
a fini turistici
l'italia dal 1998 sta perdendo quote di
mercato rispetto ad altri paesi anche se
il turismo cresce e per questo motivo è
stato deciso di dare un cambio molto
forte alla agenzia che la promuove e
virare verso il digitale è una
promozione molto più moderna e
competitiva
quando fui chiamato mi fu proposto di
svolgere questo ruolo di gestione del
cambiamento
ecco mi senti come un po oggi di fronte
a questo spettacolo imponente cioè una
di quelle cose davanti nella vita nella
quale bisogna decidere se si ha il
coraggio di affrontarle o se invece si
continua nella vita normale
ecco ci pensai molto pensai anche cosa
avrà imparato da questa esperienza e
alla fine decisi anche di mettermi in
gioco pensando che se ognuno di noi non
fa qualcosa per questo paese non
riusciremo mai a migliorare l'italia
quando ho preso diciamo sono entrato nel
mio ruolo mi sono domandato cos'è il
turismo
ecco cos'è il turismo ecco non ridete
non pensate che sia una risposta banale
una domanda ridicola quando si vuol
gestire in modo competitivo un business
molto complesso bisogna domandarsi qual
è il valore che porta faccio un esempio
dalle mie esperienze passate
prendiamo il caso delle
telecomunicazioni nokia da da essere
assente nel mercato delle
telecomunicazioni negli anni 90 divenne
leader indiscusso e bene qual era il
valore che portava nokia il telefonino
assolutamente no la l'elemento vincente
di nokia fu il motto è la vision che
tutti penso voi conoscete connecting
people
quindi il valore che portava non era il
telefonino
era il mettere in relazione le persone e
per tutti noi essere in relazione con
altri è uno dei valori fondamentali
quindi ritorniamo al turismo e pensiamo
cos'è il valore del turismo
ebbene a mio parere il turismo è
condivisione di esperienze cioè invitare
altre persone da altri luoghi a
condividere le esperienze positive che
abbiamo nel nostro territorio
amiamo le dolomiti invitiamo altre
persone per condividere con loro questa
esperienza magnifica di poterle vedere
di poterci salire il l'aspetto questo si
traduce nel fatto che non è il guadagno
e quindi ricavo dal turismo non nasce
dallo sfruttamento estemporaneo del
turista ma nasce invece dal
coinvolgimento del turista ed all'estero
in grado di offrirgli dei servizi che la
persona gradirà e per i quali ovviamente
pagherà per i servizi forniti
faccio un piccolo esempio personale
quando avevo due bambini piccoli 23 anni
andammo in una località marittima
chiaramente in spiaggia i bambini con
secchiello la paletta cominciarono a
scavare una buca
adesso voi potete immaginare che buca
possa fare un bambino di due anni
ebbene dopo un po a rivolge store e
dell'impianto e ci redarguì fortemente
perché dicendoci non è possibile scavare
buche in spiaggia dovete chiuderla
immediatamente
ecco secondo voi questo atteggiamento
era la sopportazione del disagio di
avere un turista al fine di avere un
piccolo guadagno o il voler condividere
con chi andava in quella località
l'esperienza di essere sul mare era
ahimé quella della sopportazione del
turista per un piccolo guadagno
quale fu il risultato il risultato fu
che non andammo mai più in quella
località turistica neanche quando i
figli non facevano più buche essendo
cresciuti allora cosa ci insegna
questo aspetto ci insegna che ritornando
al discorso di prima
il turismo cresce se si coinvolgono i
turisti nel senso di una condivisione di
esperienze di ciò che facciamo e
fornendogli servizi aggiuntivi non
utilizzandoli come persone per un
guadagno limitato ad estemporaneo
teniamo anche conto che oggi la
soddisfazione del singolo turista ha un
effetto immediato ea livello globale
come sappiamo chiunque diciamo condivide
le proprie esperienze sui social e
quindi l'esperienza positiva o negativa
che tutti noi amiamo condividere ha
immediatamente una risonanza a livello
globale
in questo senso dobbiamo porci qual è
l'immagine che vogliamo trasmettere e
come riusciamo a far fare un passo
avanti andando in questa direzione di
condivisione e su quali terreni muoverci
a mio parere ci sono due aspetti che
devono essere utilizzati una è
l'immagine l'altro è la sostanza
l'immagine perché chiaramente dobbiamo
promuovere i territori territori oggi
oltre 50 per cento dei turisti fa scelte
in base a internet
quindi è chiaro che dobbiamo avere una
presenza sui social importante e
positiva per poter essere nell'ottica di
far coinvolgere i turisti nelle passioni
che noi abbiamo tanti siti che elencano
che cosa ha fatto all'amministrazione
locale per i propri cittadini non sono
siti turistici i siti turistici sono
quelli che permettono di far condividere
le esperienze positive dai nostri
territori con persone che vivono lontano
e necessario quindi un forte cambiamento
culturale in questa direzione e
nell'approccio a partire da tutti le
persone coinvolte che sono tutti gli
abitanti quindi non sono soltanto gli
operatori turistici sono le istituzioni
sono i singoli
giardini prendiamo il caso di un'azienda
quando un'azienda riceve arriva un
cliente importante fino il management in
testa dell'azienda si mobilita e va
incontro al cliente importante per
testimoniare l'importanza che questo
cliente a per il risultato dell'azienda
allo stesso modo quando arrivano gruppi
numerosi di turisti o convention grandi
che vengono a visitare un territorio
sarebbe ovviamente necessario opportuno
che anche gli altri livelli delle
istituzioni locali andassero a
incontrare chi organizzato e chi porta
un numero elevato di turisti
teniamo conto che in italia il turismo
rappresenta il 10,6 per cento del pil e
crea 2,6 milioni di posti di lavoro e il
secondo settore a livello nazionale
quindi è logico e coerente che sia uno
degli elementi di primo livello di
interesse per chi governa le istituzioni
locali o nazionali
quindi allo stesso modo diciamo se
questo fatto di andare a ricevere i
grandi i grandi gruppi ha un doppio
effetto uno di invogliarli a tornare nel
nostro territori
il secondo di avere anche un effetto di
sviluppo culturale sui cittadini perché
anche i cittadini possano vedere
l'importanza che viene data a chi viene
a portare valore e posti di lavoro
l'altro aspetto ovviamente non è solo
l'immagine ma solo le infrastrutture e
qui vorrei soffermarmi su due
infrastrutture le prime sono le
infrastrutture elettroniche tutti noi da
cittadini da turisti
amiamo condividere immediatamente le
nostre esperienze
amiamo rimanere in contatto in ogni
momento della nostra vita
il turista che venisse in un territorio
non coperto da connessioni veloci
avrebbe sicuramente un impatto negativo
sia nelle negli alberghi sia nei
territori ma c'è una riflessione
importante da questo aspetto è che le
infrastrutture
non devono essere un qualcosa costruito
sulla testa delle persone del luogo le
infrastrutture devono essere pensate
come sviluppo per i cittadini del
territorio e servizi per i turisti che
arrivano se si sviluppano un posto senza
infrastrutture elettroniche oggi ha un
handicap terribile rispetto a qualsiasi
business
nessuno oggi andrebbe impiantare un
business dove non ci sono connessioni
veloci nemmeno uno turistico
allo stesso modo affrontiamo il discorso
delle infrastrutture logistiche partiamo
anche qui dal turismo
i turisti stanno accorciando spesso il
periodo di vacanza e quindi tante volte
si limitano a week end lunghi quando uno
fa un weekend lungo non può non è
ipotizzabile che spenda una giornata per
arrivare nella località e una giornata
per ritornare evidente che vuole
metterci solo qualche ora quindi le
connessioni veloci ferroviarie le
connessioni veloci agli aeroporti sono
un elemento essenziale ma anche in
questo caso torniamo al concetto
principale
questi sono un elemento essenziale per i
cittadini e anche per i turisti
cioè dobbiamo entrare in quella logica
che viene rappresentata dal fatto che un
turista avrà un'immagine positiva e la
trasmetterà quando viene a visitare un
territorio dove i cittadini sono
soddisfatti dei servizi che hanno perché
se va in giro per il paese alla città e
tutti quelli che sento di si lamentano
non potrà ovviamente riportare un
immagine positiva difficile
certo che è difficile stiamo parlando di
un business che porta in italia 160
miliardi di euro cioè essere ai primi
posti nel mondo voler essere i primi in
europa nel turismo in un settore così
competitivo e di questo valore non
possiamo pensare che sia facile
sicuramente è difficile sicuramente
vanno intraprese azioni importanti in
questa direzione
facciamo un esempio expo milano
expo milano 2015 è stato la spinta
coordinata del tutte le istituzioni e le
amministrazioni coinvolte da comune
provincia regione e stato sicuramente
con investimenti significativi ma che
hanno permesso anche di aumentare e
migliorare in modo significativo la
qualità dei servizi a milano credo che
oggi i cittadini milanesi dell'inter
l'anziano sicuramente soddisfatti del
salto di qualità che è stato fatto in
questo senso quindi ritornando al
concetto di prima expo e allo stesso
senso un frutto ma anche un'immagine
dell'impegno fatto per migliorare il
territorio
prima di concludere un commento cioè
com'è andata a finire diciamo che è
stato un anno molto intenso questo fino
alla guida dell'agenzia per il turismo
ho cercato di virare verso trasparenza e
legalità e ho progettato una nuova
organizzazione molto più all'avanguardia
rispetto agli obiettivi che abbiamo
discusso in precedenza e tra qualche
settimana
passerò le consegne al termine del mio
periodo di responsabilità i nuovi organi
che sono stati approvati dal dal governo
in conclusione
ritorniamo quindi a questo magnifico
panorama in cui siamo
e ricordiamo come le dolomiti sono
davvero
l'esempio è la sfida che tutti noi
abbiamo davanti possiamo decidere se
percorrerla o no io credo che tutti noi
abbiamo diciamo le forze da tirar fuori
per poter porci in modo positivo
rispetto a chi sta con noi alla natura
per affrontare in modo positivo e
propositivo la gestione del cambiamento
e migliorare i territori e il paese
una citazione per concludere che vorrei
condividere con voi
sulla sfida per trasformare cambiare le
cose deve essere ricordato che nulla è
più difficile da pianificare più dubbio
succederò più pericoloso da gestire che
la creazione di un nuovo sistema
per colui che lo propone ciò produce
l'inimicizia di coloro i quali hanno
profitto preservare l'antico e vi
assicuro che è vero è soltanto tiepidi
sostenitori in coloro che sarebbero
avvantaggiati dal nuovo almeno fino a
quando il nuovo non è chiaro che vinse
niccolò machiavelli il principe 1513
grazie
no